AMY SCOTT: My name is
Amy Scott and my company
is Treasured Limited.
It's basically an
online memory box.
It's somewhere to
store your memories,
in different boxes for different
people within your life.
One of the things we didn't
think of when we first designed
the product was the speed-- how
long it would take over Wi-Fi,
or anything, to get back all
of your photos within a box.
Even with phone pictures with
two megabytes per picture,
it was taking too long to bring
back a box full of photos.
So what we've actually
done, in the end,
is to take two or three
copies of each image
at different resolutions,
so that if you're using it
on your phone or the
computer, we just bring back
that fairly low
resolution picture,
but it still looks
great on the screen.
But in the database, we still
have the full size image,
so that we can use it later
for printing or as a backup,
if you're using Treasured
as a backup service.
I first came up with
the idea for Treasured
definitely with
children in mind.
When my daughter
was two years old,
and I realized I hadn't
started that memory
book that every mom is
expected to do with all
their first tooth and
first words, et cetera.
But yeah, it's
really surprised me
how my parents used
Treasured for themselves,
in their retirement, to document
all the things they are now
able to get up to, as well as
documenting their life to now,
so that they can show the
grandchildren grandma when she
was younger, and
their wedding photos,
and all of their memories
from their lifetime.
So yes, it have surprised
me, actually, that.
And the weddings.
That surprised me, too.